there are moments that I look at him
this kid that I raised and I wondered a
huius beautiful boy the film is derived
from two different memoirs David chefs
beautiful boy AB and Nick chef's tweak
both books created this singular entity
that I just imagined as a film that
could be extremely gripping it's about
my son he's addicted to crystal meth
which seems to be the worst of all of
them I heard about beautiful boy three
years ago and it was heartbroken by it
and moved by in David Sheff and Nick
chefs story is so powerful because it's
relevant and important right now
at the time when addiction just sweeping
through our country and destroying so
many families and affecting so many
communities more people are dying from
overdose than anything else under 50
years old and we're losing about 150
people every day what is your success
rate the success percentage is in the
single digits it's about a family it's
about a relationship between a father
and son and how addiction affects
relationships how really no one is safe
from it you're doing every drug on the
planet then lying really sorry there
this film spans decades and Felix found
grown again across his work like the
broken circle breakdown and now his
first English language movie beautiful
boy he does have a feel for truths about
the emotional experience of being a
human being
I'm fascinated by people who lose
themselves so I read the books and I
totally fell in love there were just so
many cinematic things that caught my
attention that it was worth spending
three or four years of my life on God
Felix's superpower to me is he just
understands human intimacy and human
relationships and familial relationships
it just has an eye on these sorts of
things how do you really want it honored
the story but also make sure that it
really felt really universal and that
everyone would be able to relate to it
nature was a big part of Nick and
David's life growing up they live in
Marin it's intensely beautiful they
spend a lot of time outside and we
wanted to show this is a boy who came
from a beautiful place this project was
particularly wonderful because we did
have a lot of access to the photos and
to the real family and we had this
really beautiful visual history of
everything that they've went through we
went up north in Marin County where we
shot the beaches and the roads we shot
San Francisco Golden Gate Bridge hits
tree tenderloin it's hard to see it all
it was right to do it there to get the
reality of it I don't feel like I have a
disease I've put myself here
you can't overstate what a treat it is
to be in front of the camera of that
sort of team and how amazing is that I
need to find a way to fill this white
hole in me it's easy to look at a movie
like this and think this involves some
pretty dark things but I see the movie
as full of joy and hope and like a real
expression of humanity towards one
another
I still have family
I want them to be proud of me
you
you